What's my name jon snow and why is my surname
snow because you're a bastard from the north
love is the death of duty
in every man's life there
comes a day when he must choose
i did what i thought was right
and i got murdered for it
kill the boy jon snow and let the man be born
Welcome back everyone hbo just announced a jon
snow game of thrones sequels series so i'll
explain what's going on because you haven't just
stepped into a time machine but this is basically
their best chance to correct a lot of the
issues with game of thrones season 8 the people
had so for those of you posting all the memes
about them re-shooting game of thrones season
8 this is kind of their way of doing something
similar of course i'll be doing episode videos
called the dance of the dragons when there
were tons of dragons all over westeros
the jon snow game of thrones sequel series will
take place after the events of game of thrones
season 8 after jon snow left to go north of the
wall with the wildlings tormund and ghost so as
of right now them announcing that this jon snow
sequel is actually happening with kit harrington
there are many game of thrones spin off sequels
and prequel shows they're doing but only some of
those will wind up actually turning into episodes
that we'll actually be able to watch on television
house of the dragon is just the first one that's
made into actual episodes that we'll be able to
watch soon i will explain all the other shows that
they're working on later in the video and i know a
lot of you are also asking if this affects kid
harrington playing the black knight for marvel
inside the turtles movies inside midnight suns
and any other big crossovers with avengers 5. i
will address that later in the video too the big
thing that i think a lot of people are confused
about is that dan and dave are not involved with
any game of thrones anything anymore so just
because hbo is doing a sequel doesn't mean that
dan and dave are coming back if you did not like
what they did with the show especially towards
the last couple of seasons don't worry they are
not involved with anything creatively or anything
like that one of the big things that they didn't
do from the books that they could always introduce
during the show one new twist with his character
is the idea of his wolf dreams and being a warg
in the books all the stark children who still
have dire wolves that continue living throughout
the series continue to have wolf dreams which is a
version of working like their low level warging
without realizing it you mostly see this play
out through arya's storyline because she sees
visions of nymeria running around through the
woods feeling like she is nymeria running around
through the woods so when people make jokes about
jon snow having a wolf brain that's what they're
talking about like him actually being a warg
it's just the tv show never bothered to do that
when the original show ended kid harrington and
the other main cast members were kind of iffy
about coming back as their characters because
everybody did ask them are you all coming back
for sequels and they're like well we don't know
right after season 8 finished the only one who
was like definitely i will come back was maisie
williams coming back as a version of arya she
actually just filmed new scenes as arya for warner
brothers as part of their big multiverses game
that's not meant to be canon to a song of ice and
fire or game of thrones that's like a completely
separate game based on all the iep that warner
brothers owns so that's how you have arya from
game of thrones interacting with dc comic book
characters this game of thrones sequel series is
legit kit harrington coming back as jon snow after
the events of season 8 to just continue the story
for at least his character now they haven't been
totally clear on exactly how much they're going
to cover in the show like is this going to be
a better call saul kind of sequel series even
though that's meant to be a prequel like well
it just focused on a specific group of characters
and have cameos from people from the original show
or will it be the breaking bad movie where it's
more of a one-off mini-series kind of thing
set after the events of the previous story
but i did a bunch of videos after the season 8
finale aired for all the deleted scenes and these
alternate endings alternate storylines that they
cut from the finale so i'll link that below in the
comments and at the end of this so you can learn
about everything that would have happened but
the game of thrones sequel series will take place
a little while after jon snow went north past
the wall the big thing in the kingdom right now
is that the wildlings with jon snow ghosts have
gone back beyond the wall and even though they've
defeated the night king and therefore killed all
the white walkers the whites that they raised
there's no more need for the actual wall like it
serves no actual purpose anymore originally it was
created 8 000 years ago after the first long night
with the combined help of bran the builder who at
the time was king of the north he was the stark's
ancestor he wasn't secretly the three-eyed raven
version of bran time traveling with his powers
there were all kinds of crazy theories about that
bran the builder was meant to be a completely
different character that was an ancestor to
these modern day characters who bran and all of
his predecessors with the same name were named
for he built the wall with the combined help of
the children of the forest and the giants at that
time and the children of the forest were the ones
who created the special magical enchantments on
the wall that prevented the white walkers and the
night king from passing through it the exception
to that during game of thrones season one because
there is a big twist with whites in castle black
is that they could carry the bodies that had
been turned into whites past the barrier through
the gate of castle black themselves and then they
reanimated once they were past the wall but before
the night king had turned viserion into the dragon
white he didn't have enough power to bring down
the wall or get past the enchantments on the show
the big difference is they condensed the timeline
so instead of the long night being like many
thousands of years ago it was closer to being
a thousand years ago still a long time but not
nearly as long eventually hundreds of years later
what wound up happening is that people in the
seven kingdoms just forgot what the wall was about
they forgot about the threat of the white walkers
and they started to believe that the wall had
been created to keep the free folk away from the
seven kingdoms but now in present day three-eyed
raven bran has become king of the seven kingdoms
samwell is his grand maester tyrion is his hand
of the king the way they portrayed things is the
realm has been to be kind of torn on what he did
killing daenerys like some of the realms supported
jon snow and some of them supported daenerys but
even though jon snow still technically has a claim
to the iron throne the great council that they
formed in this finale scene basically chose bran
to be their new king so the realm supports bran as
king but after the fact after this all plays out
he's portrayed as kind of a controversial figure
of legend amongst people in the seven kingdoms
but everybody pretty much knows that he went
north of the wall and outside of his sister sansa
who's ruling over winterfell in the north really
close by no one else is really worried about jon
snow that much like no one's really thinking about
what's going on with the wildlings because they're
not even that large of a group and even bran who
you think would be concerned about his brother jon
snow is more like a human turnip like a repository
for all of history so his personality is more like
an ai he just spits out facts and details about
things from across history anytime you try to
talk to him inaria has still left westeros to go
to the western continent on the other side of the
sunset sea to just explore what's west of westeros
gendry is now lord of the stormlands and if it
wasn't clear obviously jon snow is leading the
free folk tormund is kind of like his second in
command but a lot of you are asking who's going
to be the main villain of this show if it's going
to be centered on jon snow like what's the central
conflict if they defeated the night king the white
walkers all the whites the undead minions and the
animals they raised well they haven't said if this
is only going to take place up in the north beyond
the wall or if it'll be like a big sprawling
political thriller the way the first show was
in a lot of the villain will just depend on the
geography of the show like where it actually
takes place if it's localized to just north of the
wall it's going to be very different but like now
in present day because there's no more night king
there are no more spiders biggest hounds there are
still a couple groups in the world of essos that
hate the seven kingdoms in general and hate jon
snow for killing daenerys so like he's still hated
by a lot of people around the world and there's
further internal conflict civil war brewing
between different kingdoms inside westeros like
just because they beat the night king beat cersei
everyone went home doesn't mean that everyone in
westeros and essos now love each other one of
the big themes in george r martin's the song of
ice and fire series is that time plays out in a
circular nature like events always have a way of
repeating themselves people always make the same
types of mistakes they haven't confirmed everybody
that's coming back for the show like sophie turner
would probably come back because winterfell is
right there next door south of the wall it would
be weird for them to do this whole ass show about
jon snow for five seasons and to not show you
what's happening at winterfell or any of the
other seven kingdoms so i believe better call saul
style they will try to feature people from the
original cast the biggest antagonists left alive
at the end of the main show were the forces of
slavers bay the iron bank who really really wants
their money back now they lost a ton of money
to cersei after giving her even more loans that
she had initially paid back during season seven
like she paid back the first loan using the
tyrell's gold that they had stolen from the reach
right after they paid that loan back with
that gold they gave her another large new loan
that she used to hire the golden company which
were promptly melted by cersei in drogon they
lasted for like five seconds during that battle if
you can call it a battle it was more of a massacre
there's all the forces of the free cities there's
what's left of the dothraki the rest of the
unsullied even though grey worm implied at the end
of the main show that he was taking the unsullied
or what remained of them to noth the island where
missandei originally came from in the summer isles
in the dothraki seemed like they were eventually
going back to essos but there are many forces
inside westeros and inside essos that want
revenge for something that happened during
the events of the main show and there are a lot
of other kingdoms that they didn't feature during
the main show like other places in essos we didn't
go or didn't see a lot of really good example is
the forces of asshai in the shadow lance that's
the place where melisandre originally came from
because they just announced they started working
on this jon snow sequel series they probably
wouldn't have episodes ready till at least 2025
if they run it concurrently with the house of the
dragon episodes right now the other shows they're
still working on are the nymerian the ten thousand
ships said in the past there's one specifically
about corliss valerian the sea snake he's a
character that we're gonna see during the events
of house of the dragon but i believe it's meant to
be an older version of the character during house
of the dragon there's a dunk and egg series based on
the books about those characters remember it's sir
duncan the tall who's the ancestor of brienne the
tarth an egg is really aegon v the future king of
westeros it's also a prequel series but he's the
younger brother of maester aemon that's why when
he's dying he starts speaking about an event that
happened with his brother egg just for reference
2 jon snow's real name is aegon that would make
him aegon vi if he were to take the iron throne
there are also a couple different animated game
of thrones series that they're working on but
we don't know as much about what's going on with
the plot of those and the whole thing with kit
harrington coming back as the black knight inside
the marvel universe is that i believe that's
mostly meant to be cameo status right now i think
for a little while people were wondering if they
would do a black knight series on disney plus it
sounds like they're not doing that now and he'll
just be in future movie crossovers and that's why
he has so much extra time to do this full big
game of thrones sequel series but everyone post
all your theories in the comments below who do you
want to be the villain of this new jon snow sequel